[Applause]  Thompson for Durant [ __ ] it  Kevin Durant I tell you what next time  you see him is two in a row you may see  Bigfoot outside of the game as well  great steel right there stuffing over  LeBron James first quarter the way up by  Iguodala hit up a twin bill kept alive  by Thompson is back on his own with  Duran and Kevin Durant hits from  downtown referred three-pointer three or  four from downtown  mr. rant for three tough angle shot you  as a competitor should not settle here's  Durant he has come alive right at the  start of the third is here in Cleveland  the Brahma the spirit and in doing so  lost it it's turnover number seven for  James leading to back even for Steph  that was too deep yeah and this is the  problem right now you need help with  Tristan Thompson here's the ransom way  down town  twisting to